bautizada plataforma de solidaridad los
estados miembros de la unión europea
podrán acceder a un mecanismo que
contabilizará el número de refugiados
procedentes de ucrania en cada nación
del bloque los solicitantes de asilo y
el tamaño del país esto como una
estrategia para lograr un reparto
equitativo
en nuestra plataforma de solidaridad los
estados intercambian sus capacidades
problemas desafíos y pueden ayudarse
mutuamente
la comisionada europea de asuntos
interiores de migración aclaró que no
establecerán cuotas obligatorias para
cada país e informó que el mecanismo se
discutirá con los estados miembros el
lunes 28 de marzo y pretenden mejorar la
situación de las naciones con más número
de refugiados como polonia austria
chipre y república checa- este último
país declaró estado de emergencia el
pasado 4 de marzo por 30 días hace
algunas semanas la capital praga recibió
24 jóvenes artistas que huían de la
guerra respondiendo el llamado de
auxilio de la academia municipal de
artes escénicas y circenses de kiev
today pace crearon un programa donde
vinimos 30 personas tenemos dónde vivir
comida y un lugar donde ellos se sienten
seguros
tienen lo principal una posibilidad de
continuar con su entrenamiento que
traerá
los artistas plasman en escena sus
sentimientos y lo que vivieron en
ucrania
[Música]
con este evento recaudan fondos pero
aseguran que no olvidan a quienes
dejaron en su país
es realmente difícil entender que en mi
país hay una guerra en este momento mi
familia está en ucrania y es difícil
honestamente mantenerse normal y no
estar nervioso
según el ministro del interior de
republica checa en el país hay más de
270 mil refugiados y naciones unidas
asegura que más de 3.600.000 personas
han salido de ucrania en busca de
seguridad